Dame Kelly Holmes calls on the
government to do more on Mental Health
Plus pretty Patel the former home
secretary in her fast exclusive
interview since returning to the back
benches
[Music]
good evening violence against women and
girls is an issue that has for a long
time gripped our nation after the murder
of Sarah everard killed in London while
she was walking home many women came
forward with their own experiences of
harassment more than 90 percent of women
and girls are said they had experienced
some kind of harassment after dark and
hundreds of women are killed each year
at the hands of men it was a debate that
at times has dominated Parliament over
the last few years well now the
government is in Terminal 2 with talks
of mutiny behind the scenes and
questions about the future of Liz truss
and her government earlier I spoke to
former Home Secretary Priti Patel in her
first interview since returning to the
back bench
pretty tall thanks so much for joining
us on the show today there's so much to
talk to you about but the reason that
we're talking today is I've been doing
some more work on the matter of violence
against women and girls it was something
you cared about a lot as well secretary
and it's something that now you're not
in office that maybe you can talk about
a bit more freely what was working what
wasn't working so well and then I'll get
on to daily politics a bit more if I may
towards the end but I wanted to kick
this interview off with talking a bit
about the scale of the problem
[Music]
1772 women were killed by men in the
year to March 2021 in domestic violence
cases 200
000 cases of sexual assault in the year
to March 2022 which is probably the tip
of the iceberg because many women and
people will not report it seventy
thousand cases of rape recorded and in
May this year the ons revealed one in
two women and one six months felt unsafe
walking
home in the dark in a quiet street near
their home
harassment assault rape violence even
murder how would you describe it is it a
crisis is it an epidemic how would you
describe the problem that we are
confronting so so Beth thank you for
having me on because these are really
important and significant issues that I
think as a society we have to tackle
head-on we have to confront them and
confront the behaviors and you know the
causes behind them now I think first of
all it's important to say whether it's
domestic abuse or violence against women
and girls it does not discriminate it
affects everyone every gender every race
people from all sorts of backgrounds and
that is why certainly from my time in
government and as home secretarium Boris
Johnson as well as prime minister you
know we were Resolute in terms of our
determination to tackle these issues and
actually almost go backwards to go
forwards to bring forward the
improvements that are required so for
example
when I became Home Secretary the
domestic abuse bill was you know getting
ready to go through Parliament it was
going through key stages and we now have
a Domestic Abuse Act which has gone a
long way and this is important in terms
of providing the support for domestic
abuse victims which you know
predominantly involves women but also
let's not forget children are caught up
in that as well providing the safeguards
for them ensuring that they are provided
with homes for example working with
local authorities looking at some of the
domestic homicide reviews that
absolutely have to come with some of the
most devastating crimes such as deaths
and murders and then of course let's not
forget there's been a huge amount of
work we can talk about this a lot more
around policing the CPS getting cases to
court the evidential collection of data
and information case progression all
these types of things well in my view
quite frankly substandard and inadequate
and of course that is what we spent the
last three years working on earlier
today I went to interview Sarah crew
who's the the national lead on this who
you know well enough well with and I
asked her about whether the problem was
getting better or worse and why in terms
of prosecutions of of rape cases why
the country the is so far off sort of
levels in 2016. at a period in my career
we were able to form a specialist team
here in Avon and Somerset and we started
through a series a number of motivated
individuals looking at the problem of
sexual violence we were starting to make
progress on understanding as
practitioners how to tackle it
for a variety of reasons not least
austerity we had to make some choices in
policing and even in Somerset was no
different from other forces and that
specialism had to retract slightly now
you became Home Secretary obviously in
in 2019 and Sarah there was talking
about a storyty that was probably in the
first half of the term of Theresa man to
Boris Johnson but do you recognize that
pretty that because of funding Cuts
because of austerity that police forces
had no option but to scale absolutely
I'm the first to recognizer I mean I've
worked with Sarah I mean she's a
remarkable Leader by the way in policing
and the work that she's doing in this
particular area as a national champion
is phenomenal and we'll talk about
aspects of that but that is the reason
why as Home Secretary I was assiduous in
my determination number one to back the
police but get them the resources that
they needed to do their job because they
are one part of the criminal justice
system and I've always even before
becoming Home Secretary but as a back
bench Member of Parliament I've spoken
about the end-to-end criminal justice
system you cannot have policing working
in isolation of the CPS the crown
prosecution service or the cause because
if you're a victim of crime you want to
ensure that you're getting Justice or
access to Justice and perpetrators are
being brought
um you know to to heed basically so I've
seen this in place and don't forget I've
worked with policemen for over three
years not just on resourcing but also on
skills capability the tools tables for
example but the same time changes to
laws and legislation and the police
crime sentence in courts bill was just
one aspect of that as well where again
very specifically to violence against
women and girls and domestic abuse you
know perpetrators the sentences that
perpetrators so you begin receiving for
serious violence assault would be
increased so when you when you got into
the home office I don't want to dwell
too much on it but if you look at
um police funding yeah it had dropped by
a 16 Less in real terms between
2009 to 10 to 2018 19 when you arrived
and then with the CPS uh MOJ budget cuts
25 in real terms over that sort of
period so when you got in there did you
see that actually there is not enough
funding we need to get more resources
it's twofold
number one it's past now sure sure
number one it's a resourcing I've always
been you know I bang the drama on
resourcing but the second thing is I I
am very very assiduous about public
financing and funds you know this is how
you integrate the system you know so the
police the police working with the CPS
this is actually about how we integrate
all aspects of our criminal justice
system so it's not just policing in one
corner and the CPS in another corner
it's bringing the teams together with
your credit to Sarah crew and Ava and
Somerset for this particular type of
work on DEA and violence against women
and girls and she's brought the system
together and that is why we're now now
seeing good positive outcomes in terms
of the
violence against women and girls
strategy in December 2020 you've been
home secretary for 18 months now you
opened a call for evidence to hear
directly from the public on attacking
violence against women and girls then
three months later in March 2021 Sarah
everard was abducted we now know by a
serving police officer
and murdered and it triggered this wave
of protest and then you reopened the
call for evidence what happened then and
why did you do that so that was a
shocking period And I I think actually
the whole circumstances as Sarah
everard's disappearance let's not forget
we had covid we were all in that covered
period
um our lives had fundamentally changed
it seemed unheard of that someone a
young girl could go missing you know
actually in front of us all
and I started to ask them really
searching and probing questions around
Sarah's disappearance time it's taken to
get you know information you know all
the all the basic questions around
around her entire disappearance and it
was just absolutely awful
um and at that time of course you know
once we started to hear more about what
had happened to Sarah
I think we should be really honest I
mean the nation's Hearts just sank
um and we all felt broken in terms of
what had happened to her her
disappearance for killing her murder the
atrocities that went with her and
actually her poor family her poor poor
family as well and it just seemed right
to me to reopen the consultation there
was National outpouring there was
National grief and National outpouring
and actually National you know just just
everything we saw at the time but that
reopening of the consultation I think
did a couple of things number one it
just gave people who had probably never
thought about
given of you know letting their voices
be heard in a public consultation or a
government consultation encourage them
to come forward and Beth we had over a
hundred and eighty thousand people
um reply and respond did that surprise
your shock you or dismay I mean it's it
it didn't it didn't I don't want to say
it dismayed me I looked at it as a
chance to smoke you in the sense that
it's so
commonplace that women are saying we're
being
targeted or harassed I think first of
all it gave them the confidence to come
forward that that was the key thing it
just made me in the sense because it
spoke about if I may say so sort of
wider failure State failure you know
sort of Institutions that you know
perhaps and we know had not listened
enough to those voices so for example
we've heard this in rape cases before as
well not being victim-centric enough you
know this whole culture of disbelief and
quite efficiently well across not just
the police Criminal Justice System right
you know when evidential cases were
coming together the rape review pointed
this out very clearly and the fact that
women I think quite frankly you know
rightly so after what what had happened
to Sarah felt that this could be a
moment of change and like that for me
was a really big rallying moment and I
think was became the Catalyst for the
changes that we've definitely seen since
were you dismayed by the Mets response
at that time you remember the vigil on
clapness oh absolutely the way that was
policed there was a moment where see the
dicks Korea was hanging by I recall it
all you could have actually thrown her
under the bus I recall it all absolutely
well first the whole moment I remember I
was covering it is pretty Patrol going
to call for Cressida Dix to resign
because if she does she's gone so it was
on a Saturday night if I remember the
whole vigil and everything else you know
I brought in the inspector at the police
and inspector to actually look at
everything that had happened and ask
some searching questions and of course
since then Beth let's be very very
honest we've learned so much more about
the Metropolitan Police in terms of
conduct behaviors attitudes and you know
there is now a new chief
chief there mark Rowley who is
overseeing some fundamental reforms and
a plan that he and I agreed part of his
hundred days when he came in but it was
absolutely appalling and also I think
this is important to recognize as well
you know that lack of empathy and heart
and understanding as to what what women
were feeling and I think again it spoke
off this whole feminas culture policing
do we trust the police would we engage
with them and of course those are the
barriers that we've sought to break down
the way that the Met police start sent a
message to women that we don't
sympathize with your experience and they
were quite heartless about it well I
think that was self-evident Beth I
really do at the time and did you did
you think about asking for Chrissy to do
I was on to her well to be fair it's not
just Cresta it was into it was the
leadership team of the Metropolitan
please why didn't you well would it be
more destabilizing well it's well quite
frankly the live investigations taking
place at the time anyway and the most
appropriate way was actually to call for
the inspector to come in and ask some
proper questions to actually make sure
that you know the bar was risen the
standards standards appropriate
standards do you think that was the
beginning of the end for her as the
match I think I think it was a range of
things to be honest it wasn't just the
one incident appalling though it was it
was a range of things that we went on to
see in terms of Standards conduct
um the culture the whole culture of the
Mets misogyny and obviously that's been
subject to plenty of reports there's a
new Chief now that's obviously a new
commissioner that's overseeing the
change that's required
and you do the consultation and you get
all these hundreds of thousands of
responses you add in the ones from
before as well
and as a result uh you put 25 million to
say for Street funds you have the five
million safety for women night fund was
it ever enough is that is it ever enough
in terms of what you can do
I think it's it's more than money if I
may say so these funds are really
important safer Street funds I'm a big
champion and advocate of that around the
country they're doing great things to
give women confidence this is the key
thing that they should be free and open
to live their lives go out in the
evenings with their friends Etc that's
really really important and I think that
must absolutely continue I think the
other point about this is It's the
public awareness I think we've changed
attitudes we've raised awareness you
know we want to give people confidence
that they can come forward seek support
but I think importantly but you know I
say this as a mother as a woman as well
we want to live our lives freely and
openly right and not feel the threat of
harassment have you ever experienced on
a personal level
harassment or abuse
you have can you so I as a politician
I've been a member of parliament for 12
years over the last 12 years I've had
consistent levels of I think harassment
and abuse so harassment is just
intimidation
unkind things that obviously said to me
I have people try and follow me home
actually as well so all of that is
unacceptable the abuse much of it's
documented some of it is documented even
in Parliament you know conduct of some
MPS towards one another and myself in
particular people saying that I have no
right to speak out on certain issues
because of the color of my skin because
of my politics for example that's
unacceptable I've had a lot of death
threats um cases have gone to court that
is all simply unacceptable you think is
it worth being in the public eye if I'm
getting death threats and being abused
like that
it provides pools for thought there's no
doubt about that but I came into
politics I believe in public service I'm
very old-fashioned in that sense Beth I
do believe in public service in terms of
Vince Gates and girl the rate review uh
they set the rate review in 2021 set
targets uh to get charge levels back and
prosecution levels back to rates seen in
2016-17 that's in terms of prosecutions
just over 5 000 prosecutions a year do
you think that Target's in reach so I do
so I I absolutely believe it is in reach
and actually you've spoken to even in
Somerset you've seen the integrated work
that's taking place you've seen more
cases go to court but it's in reach for
not just those reasons
um it's in reach because of the support
that's actually going in for women so
you know the independent sexual advisors
the advers for too long we've seen a lot
of Patricia and you know I used to spend
a lot of time with victims of cryo as a
bat bench MP and you'd see people give
up because of the processes you know
long drawn out processes digital
forensics for example being too
intrusive handing over your mobile
phones we've changed that we have
changed that and that is really
important so it is it is Within Reach
and Sarah crew was hopeful it was as
well but the funding cannot be taken
away of course not of course not the
other point to make as well and is that
a message I'm going to come on to
Elizabeth is that a message to the
government as well
it's in funding so no so so Beth I think
a couple of things here basically we
have been very clear around operation
satira the work that Sarah crew and the
team are doing this this is being rolled
out to other police forces around the
country that has to happen that
absolutely has happened into the fact it
is happening I know it's happening but
also it's that integration across
Criminal Justice System the CPS the
support that goes in from the Grassroots
the community organization said first
you know I met them when I last saw
Sarah about six weeks ago these are the
ones that are making a positive impact
and they are the ones who'll hold the
hands of the victims and ensure that
they are supported that money cannot go
and the MOJ are absolutely supporting
that and it's important that we do that
you know when you when you're in
government yes there are plenty of
choices but at the end of the day you
know we have to be on the side of the
victims of crime ensure that we're
supporting them we want to prevent crime
as well obviously but we have to
absolutely ensure that people are
supported lives are devastated through
these awful crimes they really are do
you worry sometimes that some of the
measures that your Administration put in
under Boris Johnson because this is
effectively a new Administration that
they're undermining potentially some of
the work so not seeming you'll talk
about being on the side of victims but
Robert Halford was talking yesterday
about not being on the side of working
people do you worry about that a bit
well look I mean first of all this
government the new government as well
all of us were elected on the 2019
Manifesto and you know my time in
government you know was literally
focused on delivering on Manifesto
commitments it's all about the people
all about the British people you know we
we care about the public
um I always called them the people's
priorities as did Boris Johnson as prime
minister I believe in that I absolutely
believe in that that's our duty that's
our responsibility and you know I know I
know my colleagues in government
understand that you didn't run lots of
people thought you might you didn't run
for leadership neither did you come out
in support for either candidate was that
because you didn't much like the look of
either of them well I've always said
um that I was I was going to put
literally Party politics to one side
because I had huge responsibilities as
Home Secretary for me the national
security and my constitutional role in
government and I don't want to recount
what happened at the time there's
something it was chaotic over the summer
I think the Public Public saw that I had
a duty to carry on with my job and Beth
you can't be home secretary and then
come out and start joining political
campaigns and things of that nature you
know I've always taken my role seriously
and that was a position that I feel was
right I put the interest of the the
country before Party politics though I
that that for me was not even a
consideration I had the privilege of
serving as Home Secretary and put in my
country first was always a priority it's
been pretty chaotic since the summer as
well I have to say you said in your
resignation letter you give Liz truss
your support from the back benches is
she making that hard for you at the
moment well look I've I've said this
she's the leader of our party I was at
conference last birth and I said this at
conference as well we do have to come
together we've got a Clear Vision and a
clear mandate for the country it's
important that we rally behind that and
just start delivering it let me put it
another way and I won't keep pressing
you but a clear Monday for the country
is she muddy in the waters by
introducing policies not agreed by
cabinet not in the manifesto and that
has spooked the market some of the tax
measures for example do you think that
is mudgy in the waters well look I feel
myself I mean look my message is very
clear we absolutely need to get back to
delivering for the British public and
that is based on the 2019 Manifesto but
at the same time we've got to unite and
deliver for the country you know the
country is experiencing very very hard
and difficult times right now that is
self-evident yes through actions of the
government and it is important that we
put the public first the the winter is
going to be hard there's good work
that's taken place actually on energy
price caps and you know all of those
measures I think it would be useful
actually now to just make sure that we
put the public interest first deliver
for the public and make sure that we are
giving them the support that they need
through Beth what is clearly and
self-evidently going to be in some very
challenging I'm going to ask you one
thing because other colleagues have said
it and it's that the reversal of the
idea of the corporation tax cut do you
think that would be sensible now given
what's going on in the markets if you
want to put the country fast sure you
need a stable Market there's an irony to
this birth which is Market forces we'll
probably dictate some of these changes
now so you think they'll be bounced I
think I think some of this you know the
market is going to dictate this
primarily because you know we want to
see stability stability is absolute
crucial for everyone to carry on living
their lives with institutions to
function but actually for the British
people to have this you know the
stability that they need in their lives
as well and by that as well I mean
mortgages interest rates all those
crucial crucial leavers so you think
that they should do it or you just think
they're going to be forced into well
look whether those are discussions
obviously that will take place and I'm
not going to preempt anything but I
genuinely think from what we're seeing
the markets will probably dictate them
okay and my my final question to you you
were home secretary for three years
incredibly busy
insanely busy job and now you kind of
have stopped you're on the back benches
what's next for you do you want to go
back into government do you think you
might seek a career you had a successful
career before this or is your heart
always going to be in politics well look
it was the greatest honor it's the
greatest privilege to be home secretary
there's no doubt about that and toughest
job in government as well famously so
I'm a publicist yeah no doubt about that
no doubt about that you know you're
responsible for National Security there
are things that I know that many other
people never ever know
um and I was making life and death
decisions on a daily basis alongside
some of the issues that we've been
speaking about but even much wider than
that you know look at the legislation
that I've steered through Parliament the
changes that we've made to migration
should be very weird so stop doing it
well of course of course but I am a
public servant first and foremost yes I
had a career previously but I chose to
come into public service and I and I do
believe it may be unfashionable to say
that I believe in serving my country and
that's what I hope to continue to do
okay so thank you so much for joining us
on the show really appreciate your time
thank you thank you
and if you scan this QR code on screen
now you can watch that interview and all
of our interviews online plus all the
previous episodes of the show if you so
desire
well stay with us because coming up
[Applause]
the greatest name now from the Olympic
Games of this year Kelly Holmes
[Applause]
you know I never forget all the things
that have happened to me and I think
that's kind of made me the athlete I am
I've kept fighting fighting and I'm just
so in the talk
I'm glad that I never gave up my dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the symptoms of many
um they include things like excess
facial hair acne problems losing weight
infertility and not every woman has
every symptom and it's comp so common
yet many women don't know they have it
in a living for years suffering in
silence you'll go to the doctor and
explain what they are and he will take a
blood test and then you'll have a scan
of your ovaries and it's a syndrome so
you need to have at least two symptoms
to be diagnosed with PCOS initially I
found out I've had it when I was 19
years old and I've been living with the
symptoms for around four years before I
was finally diagnosed and when I went to
the doctors there was really no Clarity
around what PCOS was
um she only told me that I'd find it
difficult to have children and that was
what happened but later on in life I
ended up having six miscarriages over a
period of five years yeah one of the
symptoms of PCOS is poor air quality so
I assume that that was the reason why
and because there was no education at
school around what it was I assumed it
was that and there was no information or
any help during that time to get me
through and find out what it was well
eventually I found a recurrent
miscarriage specialist who helped me
have my children he put me on a course
of treatment that was good for women
with PCOS and of course of other
medication as well and I eventually did
have my two children the problem is that
women go for years undiagnosed and
usually it's Madness one in ten girls
will end up diagnosed with PCOS yet the
first time many women hear about it is
when they're sat in their doctor's
office and during that time they're
dealing with the you know mental and
physical anguish of the symptoms and not
knowing what what it is yeah is that a
government petition which is we need to
get 100 000 signatures to
um for the government to consider
debating the petition in Parliament and
hopefully change policy and get PCOS on
the national curriculum
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Kelly Holmes is a British Olympics
Legend winning gold in both the 800 and
1500 meters at the 2004 Olympics in
Athens before her rise to Athletics Fame
she had a career in the Army now she's
calling on the government to recognize
the importance of physical and mental
health she talked to me earlier about
her own experiences of mental health
when the pressure meant she wanted to
end her own life
same Kelly thanks so much for joining us
today now you are a national face I
think everyone pretty much in the
country knows who you are you're one of
our most celebrated Olympians you were
the first Britain in over 80 years
nearly a century to win the double the
800 and the 1500 at the 2004 Olympic
Games in Athens
you're pretty much an amazing person I
want to go back if we can to your
childhood and how it all began when did
you realize
that you had this Talent
so it was definitely at school now I
wasn't academic at school so the thing
that made me engage with it was Sport
and I remember my PE teacher kind of
taken me to the side and saying right
you have two options you can be no one
or you can focus on what you're really
good at and that is running but you've
got to believe in yourself and I've
always kind of kept that in my mind over
my career and she sent me off for a
cross-country race and I really did not
want to do it I mean everyone's memories
of cross-country at school was wet wind
muds you know kind of like I had an afro
hair Airtex Seafood shirt you know kind
of the high knee socks I didn't want to
do it at all but I came second to
against a girl who everyone knew was
really good at our age and it gave me
that far in my belly that I hated losing
and suddenly I was like engaged that was
it sport was my thing so you joined the
Athletic Club when you were 12 and then
you went on to the English schools 1500
meters this is 1983 you were 13 years
old
it was your second season and you won it
yeah so it was my first track season and
um it was 1500 meters
I suppose I wasn't really scared at that
time because when you only just starting
anything it's kind of like you've got
nothing else to worry about other than
trying to race and I remember winning
this race standing on the Rostrum and
thinking wow this is like amazing and
then I kept that going throughout my
school career going to English schools
didn't win again until I was 17. I think
because I was inspired by sport by
watching Olympic Games when I was 14
years old but your story is so
fascinating as well because then you
leave school at 16 you then go and work
in a sweet shop and you work as a care a
carer
and then you join the Army
so you are
obviously this prestigious Talent is
quite clear you are exceptionally gifted
but then you stop doing it what what
happened Kelly why did that happen so I
was inspired at age 14 uh to become
Olympic champion after watching
Sebastian Co in the 1500 meters at the
Los Angeles Olympic Games and also to be
in the Army and I think the Army gave me
a sense again of purpose it gave me a
driver and a feeling that I could do
something for myself so I tried to get
into the army over when I was 15 16 17 I
couldn't let you into you were 17 and
nine months that season I won my last
English schools Championship as well and
it also became mini Youth Olympic
champion and won a gold medal for my
country but I wanted a career I really
did I was inspired by what I saw you
know soldiers screaming and shouting at
other soldiers going under the
scrambling and over the 12 foot wall and
I was like that is it that's my life so
I ended up trying to join four years
later
you watch the Olympics again
and then you go back to training so what
what check what happened I just find
this story so fascinating because it's
so not linear yeah but you end up at the
you know the apex of the your career so
so 22 you go back to to Athletics yeah
so I'm watching the Olympic Games again
now in my back room which is a room of
your bed and you know that's where you
live and I saw this young girl who used
to race against me from Kent and she was
in this Olympic Games it was in the 3000
meters and I just looked there thinking
I mean I know her like this you're like
she's at the Olympic Games and it just
reignited the fire that I'd had in my
belly when I watched it when I was 14
years old and I just I don't know there
was something that came into my head
that that's what I want to do I really
want to be Olympic champion so I was
already competing for the Army but I was
sort of reluctantly doing it because I
loved being a soldier suddenly I find
myself at a world championships for
Great Britain you know and this the
story is actually a bit more fascinating
because
every year as an Elite Sports person you
have a national trials and that National
tiles is to get your selection for that
com that games Commonwealth Europeans
world or Olympics so you have to get
generally in the first two and a
selection time so I rock up to this
National
20093 been announced as Corporal homes
as I was at the time no one knew who I
was apart from people that knew me as a
junior and somebody said to me you're
just going to chase these two girls
they're going for the world qualifying
time so I chase them beat them and got
the qualifying time there I was finding
myself in this team so I clearly had a
bit of like competitiveness that I've
always had in my life you know you look
back on your 18 year old self that
didn't believe you could be an Olympian
was there part of you that thought I
don't I I don't know if I can make it
I'd rather do this because I think I can
succeed and I don't know about that I
think sport wasn't a career opportunity
really for you then you know what I mean
like it is now you know and even during
my career it's very amateur you know to
actually Finance your career um in sport
is reliant on being one of the world's
best and potentially sponsorship so at
the time it wasn't really a career and
now you're doing both you're training
and you're still in the Army and then at
27
I mean at 27 you go full time uh-huh
and then what happens I mean you go on
in your 30s yeah to win a double
and no it's actually a bit nuts isn't it
that's not the way around you're meant
to do it is it it really is and people
talk to me and the funny thing is is
when I won two gold medals and Athens of
course those that didn't know my career
just suddenly think I'm winning two gold
medals out of nowhere well as an
international athlete for 12 years I'd
won 11 International medals at all of
the top world class I was number between
number one and three in the world for
many many years but of course the
Olympics so the Pinnacle so most people
watch the Olympics now that was my third
Olympic game it's my first one I
actually did while serving full-time in
the military used to use my leave to go
away and compete I get a bronze so I'm
30 years old and people were like well
you must be retiring now this is the
thing you're going to be retiring and at
34 you win this double yeah did you kind
of in your mind going into that games
were you were you Did you sort of think
it's now or never this is my last shot
at this I think think at 34 I thought
the realistic thing was that would
probably be my last games but probably
what people forget is like middle
distance running and women generally
were peaking at 30s yeah anyway late 20s
early 30s and having come back into my
sport as a senior athlete relatively
late sort of a 23 realistically because
I missed that gap between Junior and
senior I kind of had that in a bag
that's always a really strong female
having served in the military physically
and mentally I suppose in one way
um so yeah just winning you know
I there's a long story and the highs and
lows were huge you know I had many
injuries which affected both my met my
mental and physical health but the one
thing I had and the one thing that kept
me going is I believed I could do it you
know you are a national figure
you are properly famous hugely
successful but there was an underbelly
tool of this wasn't there you've been
struggling with injury and you were
having some mental health issues and you
were self-harming which you then talked
about can you tell me what was going on
underneath this outward success so I
mean there's two two areas the one that
was key and was very public was the fact
that when you're trying to
reach an elite standard
um it's kind of not normal you know what
I mean you're pushing your body and your
mental capacity to the absolute limit
which maybe people don't always
understand you know it became my life it
became everything that I ever thought of
and because it was who I believed I was
at the time that was me as my identity
to be a sports person every crush or
blow was an injury or illness you know I
went through stress factors ruptured
calves torn Achilles glander fever
tonsillitis damaged femoral nerve in my
back and mental health problems
seven years out of my 12 years as an
international athlete and I got to a
point when I was 33 years old which was
a year before the Olympic Games getting
ready for a World Championships where I
had a huge breakdown because the
pressure
expectation on myself to be good one
because I was battling with other things
in my life but two because I really
wanted to be an Olympic champion and I
got to a point where I didn't want to be
here quite frankly but I did you know
you have a battle in your head when half
of you
half of you wants to live and half of
you doesn't what you mean so you felt
suicidal at times yeah absolutely
because you know you push yourself to an
extreme and
my identity at the time was purely about
sport because I didn't feel I had one as
Kelly Holmes I had one as the athlete
Kelly Holmes and so I lived on thriving
to succeed
um so when I basically became a
self-harmer in a training camp in France
because I didn't have an outlet we
didn't really talk about mental health
if you think about 2003 was there much
talk about mental health no openly no so
I didn't even know what that meant I
didn't know what a breakdown man all I
know is that I was screaming inside and
to release that pain was to hurt myself
it wasn't obviously the best thing I
could have done I could have probably
spoken to someone but I didn't know
because you get fearful of opening up do
you mean that in terms of your career
that because Kelly Holmes because your
identity was Elite athlete if your body
was injured you would feel what's the
point of Kelly Holmes if I can't if I
can't run and win then I'm what's the
point of that's how you fail yeah that's
really tough yeah yeah I really did and
it was hard because all I had in my
mindset was this Olympic games because I
never not just that one Olympic games
but being a world-class Olympic of
Olympian and having a absolute
I don't know where it come from but I
always believed I'll be Olympic champion
and so the prospect of that not
exceeding yeah was something you
couldn't even forgive yourself for even
though some of the injury problems are
out of your control right they're out of
your control but I also think that in
hindsight it made me who I am you know
now post it I believe in fate you know
before it was just hell but post it I
think well I was meant to go through
this journey you know I was meant to
fight to earn it because I didn't think
I'd win two gold medals I mean who
dreams wakes up and thinks yeah I can be
a double Olympic champion you know it's
not something a deemed of but I did it
because I remember watching you
like the nation watched you and then for
you to achieve that but then be open
about what was really going on that they
can be outwardly successful but they're
battling issues that aren't being
discussed it's actually quite Brave was
it hard to talk about it or was it
cathartic so I didn't speak about it to
anyone until I retired yeah in 2005
that's what I made my first thought to
biology
the reason being because I actually
never knew how to talk about it so how
when people say to me well how did you
get off of being the lower the low and
win two gold medals the reason why is
because I opened up a lot more to my
team around me about needing help and
support but not about the mental health
side because I still didn't know how to
do that but what I did is bring on board
and say look I know I can do this if I
stay injury free because actually being
the lowest low I couldn't go any lower
with what I'd gone through over my
career so in a way that made me
empowered me to go if I can still win
medals so in my head it drove me to
success so I bought people around me
like you would in any area of life I
bought people who believed in me people
that could keep me healthy and Industry
keep me motivated I was still
self-harming but there were moments when
it was reminding myself of
reminding myself of what I'm going for
what I've gone through it was like
always a cry for help but it was
lessened because when I wasn't getting
injured I felt better so you you knew
when you were you knew about your
sexuality you said when you were 18 but
you kept that hidden for over three
decades you kept that as a secret
um why did you keep that hidden for so
long
yeah I mean it is a long story but it's
um
I suppose the significance of it is that
Health became an issue in terms of how
you feel about yourself so during covid
we all cope with things very differently
didn't we you know I actually became a
bit of a gym bunny I was doing
everything because I was at home you
know and going out running using the
time that we had to do it yeah I got
covered and because I am someone that
likes to keep active keep fit and then
I'm laying out for three weeks it drove
me insane and it was almost then the
start of me thinking uh about just how I
feel about myself it really kind of had
an impact and it just made me realize
that you know life
life can be so short for so many people
and I just thought to myself do you know
what I want to start living
my authentic life I want to be me and so
I decided that I needed to at some State
talk about the authentic me which is
being a gay woman in public I mean I've
always been it to my friends and family
so your friends and family knew yeah it
was just
so it's that public thing that I had to
get secret and a lot of it was to do
with my time in the Army but it had an
effect on my mental health
hugely because I thought I don't want to
die with my friends and family saying
what isn't a shame that she just can't
be herself so the impacts on my mental
health were huge
through my whole career but of course I
was able to hide
the talk of mental health through my
sporting career so sport has actually
been my savior for lots of different
reasons when I read about you coming out
you you said you called your Brigadier
basically your Superior in the Army to
to ask about that now lots of people go
why on Earth were Kelly
need feel the need to do that well put
it in a very short way there was a ban
in the military that stopped people
homosexuality and that band only got
lifted in 2000 I served during that ban
and also there was no talk about
sexuality in sport either
an international sport you wouldn't you
wouldn't really talk about homosexuality
in sport or in the military so for me I
had these overarching fears in in Broad
in my life for so long that fear is
debilitating you can't just suddenly let
go of fear and the only way I felt that
I could change that was to know there'd
be no repercussions if I publicly said
that I was a gay woman from the Army
even though I have a complex
relationship with the Army because I'm
an honorary Colonel you're
groundbreaking because you were hugely
successful as an Olympian but you talked
about mental health and you're
groundbreaking because you were
successful in the Army and a successful
Sportsman and you talked openly about
sexuality so two things that you battled
with then you spoke about that
that help other people no doubt to open
up I wanted to ask you about this about
whether things are changing you know the
prince and princess of Wales were on
radio one this week or newsbeat talking
to younger people about World Health day
and about how people need toolboxes to
talk about mental health do you think
that things are getting better that
people
are able to talk about there isn't such
a stigma
I do think we're getting there I do
think it all comes with anything about
visibility transparency and seeing
people talking and having that platform
we're safe to talk I think people who
are in the public eye Who start talking
in that realm it makes other people that
have either watched you or been inspired
for you think oh okay it happens to
anybody so I do think there's empowering
people who are their public talking
um to help those that feel isolated or
feel that there's no way they could ever
do it in their life I do think there's a
power to that so I do think it's
changing I think it changes but it's
there's more that needs to happen and
you were talking about the pandemic and
your own mental health and you know lots
of people I think I think I read two
million people are suffering from long
covered obviously there were huge
challenges of the lockdowns and
isolation
um a big impact on the nation's mental
health and now we've got a cost of
living crisis do you think that we are
or do you worry
that things are going to get worse
because of the sort of two
huge and quite external events that have
kind of Knocked
both sort of nationally knocked us all
but just individuals struggling with
The Fallout of covid struggling with
with current sort of anxiety over how to
make ends meet absolutely so um I've
been working with knuffled health who
have produced a sort of
index basically and done some
research on the impact of mental and
physical well-being and it shows that
one in three people as mental health has
absolutely got worse over the last 12
months it's a lot that's having a huge
impact on society generally I mean if
you think you mentioned around the cost
of living
around the access to support you know
people are suffering young and old are
suffering and I do think that the
government as a whole have to take some
action to recognize that physical and
mental health goes side by side
so when you're talking about impacts on
society generally people who are not
taking up the jobs and there's plenty of
jobs out there you know why is this
happening you know why is people's
mental health deteriorating
they have to look at this to put well
we're trying to fight for a 10-year
Strat you know a 10-year kind of uh a
proposal so that the government actually
put out like let's say a legislation to
say that they both are both as important
as each other because I've seen it so
they're saying that the government
guidelines or the health guidelines is
150 minutes of moderate activity per
week moderate activity is just a brisk
walk
Nationwide the average is 65 minutes per
week that means just over 10 minutes a
day we might be briskly walking that's
it
so why are we getting more obese why is
our mental health uh getting really bad
why is there a huge issue with teenage
mental health and suicide because we're
not looking at the importance of being
active and how that correlates with up
here so you would like number one you
think that the government should have a
proper 10-year strategy about trying to
improve the nation's Health yeah and
that needs to be linked to trying to
encourage people to be more active
because we know the link between
physical activity and improve mental
health we'd like the government to
publish a 10-year strategy where it
combines the importance of mental and
physical health well-being being on par
of each other because we know that there
is a really big correlation between both
they are so important so I talk about
in a way that negative side of me
pushing to be an elite athlete and the
pressures it had on my mental health but
I now have to do and be active for my
mental health I have to get out and do
something whether that's in the gym
whether that is just a walk to breathe
to take the stresses and pressures that
I might feel whether that is calling a
mate and saying you fancy going out you
know for a run do you fancy doing even
an online workout Core workout with me
these days I have to do that just to
feel good do you think do you think the
moment the government are letting
people down on Mental Health
you do I do because we're not recognized
as the importance of them going side by
side yeah yeah I think you know
it's a huge
if you look at the impact of mental
health and how the stats have risen to
those that are suffering and then the
costs on the NHS because they're having
to combat people's mental health
problems why aren't we realizing that
they go side by side your message would
be if you could sort of see you know if
the health secretary's watching this and
she could make one change now
what sort of thing would it be Kelly
would it be more provision for sport in
schools would it be more free access to
gyms for the public what what sort of
practical things would you say please
can you introduce this
um I think firstly
to recognize and publish as joint
strategy for mental and physical health
so that money and you know whatever
money goes to People's Health
it recognizes that it's for mental and
the physical side whatever that may be
I think that
when we're looking at it
the cost of living is huge so if we're
talking about people I say eating
healthier if the cost of our shopping
let's say is getting so far out there
what are people going to do get the
Quick Fix cheap uh products most of
those aren't that healthy you know
because all the healthy things seem to
be expensive so why don't we look at
just that cost of living in terms of our
health generally definitely the
provision for people to access more
facilities to do more sport if you're
from a disadvantaged area of deprivation
you don't have the means you don't have
the access yet your health is actually
worse off because of that
um of course schools need to prioritize
the need for it to become a priority
that kids do more PE and activity in
school time they're neglecting this
they're putting it on to coaches putting
it on to parents to facilitate it out of
school what does mental health do when
you feel so I can say when I do
something active and I know this I feel
good like I'm more aware I'm kind of
ready to go I feel good in myself same
with young people you know you need to
get them moving make them feel better
about themselves they'll be more
attentive in school just in terms of
your journey with mental health and
Sport we saw some examples of that with
very very successful female athletes
over the past year there was Simone
bills the amazing gymnast who had to
pull out of some of the competition in
the Tokyo Olympics we had the tennis
star Naomi Osaka pulling out from the
French Open Over mental health issues
presumably one you could resonate with
how they're feeling and two do you think
it's progress that they're able to do
that rather than keeping it hidden in a
way because both of them were quite
criticized in different ways weren't
they I think it's brilliant that these
young people in sport are having the
confidence and ability to talk about the
effects that they're having as young
people through their mental health
problems
regardless of the fact that they're
world-class athletes are human beings
first and foremost and then we have to
look at that you know people need
support people need access to talk but
they need a safe environment so you need
to be able to open up and express it I
do think that when you get people coming
out who are young and talking about the
impacts as long as there's backed up by
their support mechanisms there's a huge
amount of Charities out there I must say
that anyone that is suffering and
listening to our conversation there's so
many Charities out there that can
support you through this journey because
most of it's about conversation once you
have conversation you open up you get
that support it could be a huge relief
Dame Kelly Holmes thank you for spending
some time it's absolute pleasure to talk
to you today thank you so much thank you
and if you scan that QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
Beth Rigby interviews podcast a new
episodes available each week and I take
a look at the highlights of my
interviews and there's some extra bits
and pieces in there too that's on the
Sky News app or wherever you get your
podcasts
well that's all for today's show thank
you so much to Our Guest Dame Kelly
Holmes and pretty Patel and thank you
for watching hope to see you next week
[Music]